maske oder keine maske deutschland
diskutiert die gesundheitsminister der
länder wollen dass der schutz bleibt
eine studie für zdf wiso zeigt nur ein
viertel der online-händler gibt die
niedrigere mehrwertsteuer wirklich an
die käufer weiter
[Musik]
gänsehaut garantiert ennio morricone der
komponist von spiel mir das lied vom tod
ist im alter von 91 jahren gestorben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und narben willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag norbert lehmann ist auch dabei
für den sport einen schönen haben doch
familie
so hatte sich das der
wirtschaftsminister von mecklenburg
vorpommern sicher nicht vorgestellt da
denkt er am wochenende laut darüber nach
die masken pflicht im einzelhandel
abzuschaffen weil es im norden kaum noch
corona fälle gibt und was folgt
allgemeines kopfschütteln und ein
einstimmiges nein aller
gesundheitsminister an der stadt fällt
berichtet filialleiterin evelyn hoffmann
schaut sorgenvoll durch ihr modehaus in
schwerin seit shoppen mit maske zur
pflicht geworden ist verzeichnet sie 30
prozent weniger umsatz und auch das
kaufverhalten der kunden hat sich
verändert
sie gehen gezielt also das große
schlendern oder shoppen das herz schon
online stellen wird bekommt für den
moment wie lange dieser moment andauert
darüber wird jetzt heftig diskutiert
mecklenburg vorpommerns
wirtschaftsminister harry glawe hatte
die abschaffung der masken pflicht für
den einzelhandel im land in aussicht
gestellt sein niedersächsischer kollege
unterstützte ihn
ich glaube im einzelhandel da wo
mindestabstände gewahrt werden können wo
man weit genug auseinander bleibt und
ich glaube das ist das entscheidende
kann man zumindest darüber nachdenken
gegenwind bekommt der masten vorschlag
von bundesgesundheitsminister wir haben
so viele aktive infektionen auf der welt
wie noch nie zuvor an einem einzigen tag
das heißt wir müssen weiter aufeinander
achten und maske tragen insbesondere in
geschlossenen räumen
dort wo der mindestabstand nicht immer
gewährleistet ist maske tragen schützte
ein selbst aber vor allem auch die
anderen lockerungen der masken pflicht
im handel in mecklenburg vorpommern kann
sich virologe andreas pott bielski
vorstellen
allerdings solle jedes geschäft geprüft
werden
ich meine weiterhin das einen relativ
enger laden mit einer schlechten
belüftung er eine situation ist in der
ich zu uns persönlich weiterhin einen
guten schutz tragen würde
in mecklenburg vorpommern soll nach der
politischen sommerpause über die
abschaffung der masken pflicht erneut
diskutiert werden
im modehaus kressmann würden sie sich
darüber freuen
zum aktuellen corona stand in
deutschland ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen leicht gestiegen
im schnitt der vergangenen woche haben
sich täglich 400 menschen neu mit dem
virus angesteckt gestern waren es noch
390 kontakt beschränkungen gab es
zuletzt nur noch im kreis gütersloh nach
mehr als 1500 infektionen in einer
schlachterei der firma tönnies war dort
die kritische zahl von 50 fällen pro
100.000 einwohner deutlich überschritten
jetzt aber hat ein gericht die maßnahmen
vorläufig außer vollzug gesetzt
warum das erklärt uns jetzt felix
zimmermann aus unserer rechts redaktion
felix warum geht das gericht davon aus
dass diese beschränkungen im kreis
gütersloh verfassungswidrig sind
das gericht begründete die entscheidung
mit den massenhaft durchgeführten corona
tests kurz nach dem ausbruch und diese
hätten ihm gezeigt dass sich das virus
eben nicht im gesamten kreis gütersloh
ausgebreitet hat sondern das
infektionsgeschehen sehr lokal begrenzt
geblieben ist und daher sei es
unverhältnismäßig im gesamten kreis mit
350.000 einwohnern weiter die ausgangs
beschränkung beizubehalten
es müsste differenzierte regelungen
geben das heißt da wird das sich
landräte bürgermeister und auch
ministerpräsidenten künftig noch genauer
überlegen müssen ob sie corona
beschränkungen anordnen ja so ist es
weniger ob anordnen wenn da sagt das
gericht kurz nach dem ausbruch
da ist es gerechtfertigt dass man erst
mal zur klärung der situation auch
weiträumige lokale verbote verhält
sobald dann aber klar ist dass es
wirklich nur bei einem lokalen ausbruch
geblieben ist muss sofort umgesteuert
werden
denn freiheitsrechte die können
natürlich nur dann gerechtfertigt
eingeschränkt werden dann wirklich eine
gefahr für die gesundheit der
bevölkerung droht
insofern könnte dieses urteil
signalwirkung haben etwa wenn es zu
einem neuen lokalen ausbruch kommt oder
zu der befürchteten zweiten welle
interessante infos dankeschön felix
zimmermann
das verteidigungsministerium hat sich
dafür ausgesprochen bewaffnete
kampfdrohnen für die bundeswehr
anzuschaffen
solche drohnen sind umstritten auch in
der koalition deshalb hatte es in den
letzten monaten anhörungen mit
politikern militärs und zivilen experten
gegeben
jetzt muss der bundestag darüber
entscheiden bisher setzt die bundeswehr
nur unbewaffnete aufklärungs drohnen ein
und jetzt zum kampf um die macht in der
union csu-chef söder hatte die debatte
am wochenende kräftig angefeuert mit
seiner aussage der künftige
kanzlerkandidat der union müsse sich in
der korona krise bewährt haben wieder
eine spitze gegen die drei bewerber
heute nun betonte der bayerische
ministerpräsident mehrfach sein platz
sei in bayern auf die frage ob er eine
eigene kandidatur ausschließe ging
solange keine vor unsere gunther love
energy in berlin kann es der union recht
sein kann es der cdu recht sein dass
markus söder in dieser wichtigen frage
den takt vorgibt
wenn das dürfte vor allem der cdu
parteiführung nicht recht sein die sich
das alles ganz anders vorgestellt hat
sie hat heute hier hinter mir im
adenauer-haus getagt per video-konferenz
und wollte sich dabei auf sachthemen
konzentrieren masken pflicht zum
beispiel oder die zustände in der
fleischindustrie darüber hat man hier
gesprochen und dass jetzt die
kanzlerkandidatendebatte losbricht vor
der sommerpause das beunruhigt hier doch
den 1
anderen denn das ganze längst natürlich
den blick auf das führungs vakuum in der
cdu damit kann man nicht mit punkten man
kann besser punkten mit krisen
management das hat sich in den umfragen
gezeigt in den vergangenen monaten da
lief es für die cdu ganz gut und
deswegen dürfte hier die parteiführung
auch sehr erleichtert gewesen sein zu
hören dass markus söder heute schon
wieder leicht zurück gerudert ist heute
morgen in einer pressekonferenz hat er
gesagt das würde ja nun niemandem helfen
in der sommerpause diese debatte zu
haben
auch annegret kramp-karrenbauer soll
hier gewarnt haben berichten teilnehmer
der video konferenz dass man sich die
sommerpause nicht durch diese debatte
bestimmen lassen soll
sie hat auch angekündigt dass sie mit
den offiziellen kandidaten für den cdu
vorsitz also friedrich merz norbert
röttgen und dem duo sparen laschet in
den kommenden wochen gemeinsam weitere
schritte besprechen möchte dankeschön
für diese information aus der hauptstadt
dank unterlag zum ersten juli hat die
bundesregierung die mehrwertsteuer
gesenkt in der hoffnung damit den konsum
wieder zu beleben ob das klappt ist
offen
insbesondere online-händler passen ihre
preise oft mehrmals täglich an ob sie
die steuersenkung weitergeben können
kunden dann nur schwer nachvollziehen
die kollegen von wieso haben sich das
genauer angeschaut susanne pohlmann
berichtet 50 ja sogar 70 prozent
günstiger
es ist eine rabattschlacht mit der die
geschäfte versuchen die kunden
anzulocken und die mehrwertsteuersenkung
wird hier ebenfalls weitergegeben
doch wie steht es um den online handel
seit der korona krise haben viele
menschen ihre shoppingtour ins netz
verlegt wie steht es hier um die
mehrwertsteuersenkung das hat clemens
festpreis analyst und marktforscher
exklusiv für das zdf untersucht sein
team hat die preise von 3000 produkten
bei verschiedenen anbietern über einen
zeitraum von mitte juni bis anfang juli
verglichen ergebnis nur gut ein viertel
der beobachteten preise wurden seit dem
ersten juli gesenkt knapp drei viertel
blieben gleich oder stiegen sogar an
schlechte nachrichten also für
schnäppchenjäger
auch eine beliebte variante einige
anbieter den preis vor dem ersten juli
deutlich anheben um ihn dann nur ein
bisschen zu senken
der kunde spart nichts am ehesten werden
noch die preise im bereich elektronik
gesenkt bei spielzeug und auch bei
drogerieartikeln wie kosmetik oder
parfüm ist das weniger der fall
mein tipp wäre aber geduld mitbringen
produkte beobachten produkte vergleichen
zum richtigen zeitpunkt zu schlagen
generell schwanken die preise im online
handel deutlich mehr als im
ladengeschäft die aktuelle
mehrwertsteuersenkung spielt kaum eine
rolle
mehr dazu bei wie so direkt nach uns die
kompletten ergebnisse des preis 6 finden
sie auch online wo verbraucher sparen
können stationär oder im internet alles
zum nachlesen in der zdf- heute app wie
schnell sich die korona situation wieder
verschärfen kann zeigt sich aktuell in
spanien das land hatte ja die meisten
infizierten in der gegend monate lang
dürfen die menschen dort nicht aus dem
haus dann gab's lockerungen und jetzt
werden wegen akuter infektionsgefahr
wieder zwei gebiete abgeregelt in
galicien gelten seit heute ausgangs
beschränkungen im landkreis amarena und
in katalonien wurde die gegend um die
großstadt jeder bereits am samstag dicht
gemacht
in beiden provinzen sind mehr als
270.000 menschen betroffen
thomas weide
polizeikontrollen rund um das
katalanische later wer das gebiet
betreten oder verlassen will braucht
eine ausnahmegenehmigung nach dem
wochenende hatten die behörden mehr als
4000 aktive fälle von kogit 19 gezählt
wir denken dass wir in leder besondere
maßnahmen ergreifen müssen um die
anfälligsten menschen zu schützen um
unsere gesundheitszentren zu stärken und
die krankenhäuser selbst auch an anderen
orten in spanien bekämpfen die behörden
cluster von kogit 19
im baskenland richten sie heute ein
neues testzentrum ein nachdem sich in
einer bar sieben menschen infiziert
haben
wir haben all diejenigen personen
kontaktiert die mit diesen sieben
menschen in berührung kamen die
angehörigen haben wir bereits getestet
und alle die gestern in die betreffende
balingen haben wir bereits heute morgen
sehr früh getestet reisen nur mit
besonderer genehmigung in galicien
bekämpfen die behörden an den örtlichen
cupid 19 ausbruch einige touristen
gerade angekommen reisen brummt wieder
ab wir hatten angst weil wir nicht
wissen was passiert und für den fall
dass sich die maßnahmen ändern haben wir
beschlossen lieber zu gehen
das und restaurants in galicien dürfen
nur die hälfte ihrer plätze nutzen das
dämpft einmal mehr die hoffnung dass
spanien aus eigener kraft die
wirtschaftskrise hinter sich lassen kann
auch israel hatte die hoffnung das
schlimmste in sachen corona überstanden
zu haben
doch jetzt ist klar das virus ist zurück
und zwar stärker denn je
die zweite welle hat israel voll
erwischt noch im mai sah es sehr gut aus
doch dann der dramatische anstieg
rekordwerte bei den täglichen
neuansteckungen am samstag waren es über
1000 bei neun millionen einwohnern
nicola albrecht nationalen notstands
lage nennt der israelische premier
netanyahu den status an der korona front
angesichts von rekord infektionen mit
stark steigender tendenz
auch wenn davon außerhalb der
testzentren nichts zu sehen ist wir
gehen eben gerne aus feiern gerne und
nachdem der premierminister gesagt hat
geht feiern haben wir das gemacht das
war im mai als israel fast virus frei
schien und netanjahu die strikten
maßnahmen fast vollständig aufhob und
jetzt zurück zum lockdown das will der
premier unbedingt verhindern
alle bürger israels müssen verstehen
dass wir beschränkt maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen mit den geringst möglichen
auswirkungen für die wirtschaft
tatsächlich ist der druck aus wirtschaft
und gesellschaft auf die regierung enorm
die arbeitslosigkeit ist virus bedingt
auf 20 prozent gestiegen
doch nicht an jahres top corona berater
warnt vor den möglicherweise falschen
prioritäten
wir haben die kontrolle über die
pandemie verloren so bereits in zwei
wochen reichen vermutlich die
kapazitäten des gesundheitssystems nicht
mehr
wir brauchen landesweite maßnahmen und
zwar dringend
netanya setzt auf die überwachung der
bevölkerung durch den geheimdienst
handyortung soll helfen infektionsketten
zu identifizieren
am nachmittag ordnet er zudem an die
gästezahl in restaurants zu limitieren
bars und clubs müssen ganz schließen die
geldstrafe für das brechen der masken
pflicht wird erhöht streng kontrolliert
wird allerdings bislang nicht und die
maßnahmen müssen noch vom parlament
gebilligt werden
nach kroatien dort haben die regierenden
konservativen die parlamentswahl klar
gewonnen
zur absoluten mehrheit reichte ist für
die partei von ministerpräsident
language aber nicht er braucht also
einen koalitionspartner
die sozialdemokraten landeten deutlich
dahinter ihr parteichef bartsch kündigte
seinen rücktritt an
die wahlbeteiligung lag bei historisch
niedrigen 46 prozent starke nebenrollen
haben ihn berühmt gemacht am liebsten
spielte tilo prückner kauzige typen wie
jetzt bekannt wurde starb der gebürtige
augsburger bereits vergangene woche im
alter von 79 jahren
wenn man nicht mehr hat außer der ire
da spielte in dem film und
fernsehproduktion zb in der zdf
krimireihe kommissarin lucas auch im
tatort und vielen theaterstücken war er
zu sehen und stand bis zuletzt vor der
kamera seine filmmusik kennen sie alle
zum beispiel aus dem western zwei
glorreiche halunken
[Musik]
und das ist nur eine von hunderten
melodien des wohls größten film
komponisten aller zeiten ennio morricone
der das talent besaß die seele eines
films in musik zu fassen
vergangene nacht ist der
oscar-preisträger mit 91 jahren in rom
gestorben christoph volkert erinnert
[Musik]
es ist dieser sound diese melodie die
ihn weltberühmt
gemeinsam mit seinem schulfreund sergio
leone neue musik für eine neue art von
western und doch kränkt es ennio
morricone zeitlebens von vielen nur auf
diese reduziert zu werden
das ist eine sehr eingeschränkte sicht
sie müssen wissen dass western gerade
einmal acht prozent meines werkes
ausmachen
als sohn eines musikers wird er 1928 in
rom geboren er studierte trompete und
komposition arrangiert musik fürs radio
komponierte opern schlager pop und macht
auch experimentelle musik
nach außen gibt er sich stets nüchtern
er komponiert klassisch mit bleistift
und papier nach festen regeln
woher aber die magie seiner musik kommt
bleibt auch ihm ein rätsel
keine ahnung das weiß ich auch nicht
mehr als 60 jahre 600 alben unzählige
preise
wichtig scheint ihm dabei nur eines dass
seine musik zeiten und filme überdauert
auch beim schreiben fürs kino habe ich
mein leben lang darauf geachtet dass die
musik für sich selbst steht sie muss
autonom sein ihr eigenes leben haben
[Musik]
ihr eigenes ewiges leben wenn ihr
modernes werk wird bleiben
[Musik]
nach gott muss man mit tollen und du
musst jetzt vor allem mit fußball
emotional mithalten
bundesliga-relegation absolut spannend
heute abend das rückspiel zwischen dem
noch zweitligisten heidenheim und dem
noch erstligisten bremen nach dem für
werder enttäuschenden 0 0 im hinspiel
droht bremen der erste abstieg seit 40
jahren ja und heidenheim steht dagegen
vor dem größten erfolg der
vereinsgeschichte
viel fehlt nicht mehr nach dem 0 0 in
bremen ein heimsieg heute abend und
heidenheim wäre zum ersten mal
erstklassig es ist wichtig dass wir
genauso leidenschaftlich auftreten wie
in bremen und trotzdem klar in der sache
bleiben
heidenheim muss mehr aus seinen chancen
machen als im hinspiel und defensiv
sicher stehen
teamgeist leidenschaft und kampf sind
heidenheim stärken gegen den taumelnden
bundesligisten bremen für den es nach
einer verkorksten saison in einer partie
um alles geht sportlich ist werder
besser aber bei rage zu sakko und co
muss im finale gegen den abstieg auch
der kopf mitspielen
es wird auch ein thema der ersten sein
das ist ja gar keine frage und wir
wissen alle es gibt keinen danach und
diesmal gibt es wirklich keinen danach
es gibt gar keine hintertür mehr
spannender könnten die voraussetzungen
kaum sein vor diesem relegationsspiel
heidenheim gegen bringen
ja und die highlights dieses
relegationsspiel spitz bei uns heute
abend zu sehen im zdf in einer
ausführlichen zusammenfassung um 23 45
nach dem abgang von trainer dieter
hecking hat der hamburger sv einen
nachfolger gefunden
daniel tunen bislang coach beim vfl
osnabrück wechselt zum zweitligisten
zweitliga-konkurrenten an die elbe der
deutsche sport trauert um die zehnkampf
legende willi holdorf der olympiasieger
von tokio starb im alter von 80 jahren
unvergessen die bilder vom 19 oktober
1964 der abschliessende 1500 meter lauf
kurz vor dem ziel
holdorf völlig erschöpft mir wurde
schwarz vor den augen berichtete er
später
am ende siegte er mit elf sekunden
vorsprung von seinem kontrahenten aus
der damaligen sowjetunion willi holdorf
war der erste deutsche überhaupt der bei
olympia als zehnkämpfer
die goldmedaille holte 1964 tokio das
war übrigens die letzte gesamtdeutschen
olympiamannschaft bis zur
wiedervereinigung wahnsinn und wir
zeigen ihnen noch wie sinnlich und
ästhetisch corona regeln kommuniziert
werden können und zwar in südkorea 300
beleuchtete drohnen über dem himmel vom
sohn ihre botschaft bitte mindestabstand
einhalten und händewaschen nicht
vergessen
ein computer koordinierte das ballett
den nur 300 gramm schweren drohnen
das wetter bleibt zweigeteilt im norden
schauer im süden sonne die details hat
gleich gunther tiersch marietta slomka
freut sich auf sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal und wir freuen uns wenn
sie morgen in der fussball halbzeitpause
dabei sind kurz nach 7
haben sie noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
unheimliche zuschauer es gibt gute
nachrichten der starke wind wird morgen
deutlich schwächer und es wird wieder
etwas wärmer aber letztendlich kommen
wir nicht aus der talsohle temperaturen
in mitteleuropa raus ganz anders über
osteuropa ukraine russland 30 35 grad
und unerträglich die hitze morgen im
süden von spanien mit firma und schaut
sich bei uns wird die kommende nacht
wieder ziemlich frisch etwa fünf bis elf
grad sind es zwölf grad an den küsten es
wird anfangs vielleicht an den alpen
noch etwas regnen später lockert auch
dort aufs funkeln die sterne dann nur an
der nordsee gibt es weitere regenschauer
in dieser nacht und die dringen dann
morgen tagsüber in norddeutschland
weiter ins landesinnere berlin werden
sie wohl kaum erreichen und dann beten
nur noch an der küste dieser kräftige
westwind sonst wird nur noch ein
schwacher wind die sonne kommt raus über
den mittelgebirgen auch in
süddeutschland wolkenlos der himmel im
schwarzwald schwäbischer alb aber auch
an den alpen und die temperaturen
steigen noch etwas an 19 bis 24 grad
meist nur im norden etwas frischer 16
bis 18 grad und die aussichten es wird
bei dieser zweiteilung der temperaturen
bleiben donnerstag gibt schauer in der
mitte deutschlands freitag erreichen die
am späten nachmittag mit gewittern dann
langsam auch die alten ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut